josée legault
alec castonguay michel david christian
dufour bonsoir je vais vous donner le
temps peut-être les gens l'ont entendu
plus tôt sinon je vous fais en attente
et monsieur legault dans sa présentation
de cette proposition en écoutant cette
loi 96
quant à va être adopté ça va être le
geste plus fort qui aurait été posée
depuis le dépôt de la loi 101 en 1970
qu'un geste qui est très fort dans ce
qui est proposé c'est le français langue
de travail
pour moi c'est très important d'envoyer
ce signal fort qu'au québec pour
travailler il faut parler français je
pense un bon compromis qu'on présente
pense que ça va donner des résultats
puis qu'on va réussir à inverser la
tendance qu'ont mpo actuellement
alors on va y aller par étapes si vous
le voulez bien
on va commencer par les commerces et les
entreprises monsieur legault disait ça
va être extrêmement important
on souligne le droit d'être servis en
français
on va voir le tableau on souligne
l'application de la charte aux
entreprises de 25 employés et plus et
l'affichage en français qu'on veut
rechercher est-ce que ça c'est de nature
à changer les choses josé de boue sur le
court terme c 'est c'est difficile à
dire parce qu'il ya eu un tel laisser
aller tel relâchement dans les derniers
25 savoir prendre justement du temps
avant que certaines habitudes se
reprennent dans les milieux de travail
il n'empêche que c'est en effet un
signal par monsieur legault en raison
aussi
c'est la première série de modifications
qui dans les faits renforce la loi 101
au lieu de l'affaiblir parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'il ya eu des réformes c'est être
toujours à la pire c'était pour la paix
blir en réaction à des jugements de
tribunaux
donc je pense que des larges et aussi
les comités de francisation aux
entreprises de 25 employés et plus c'est
un geste aussi important ça prend pas
plaisir mais c'est nécessaire et ça je
pense que ça va aider aussi art
conscientiser et les francophones sur
leur droit de travailler en français et
d'être servis en français et les
allophones et les anglophones sur leurs
devoirs aussi de laisser de travailler
en français et de servir des trois
quarts très bientôt de table qui se
poursuit sur qu'une grand-mère ces
entreprises parce qu'on veut revenir
après au cégep l'ami alec dans un projet
de loi qui ratisse aussi large ça fait
jamais la sphère de tout le monde sait
que les angles les organismes très
militant pour la défense du français
aurait voulu par exemple qu'on revienne
elle
l'égoïsme dans l'affichage un bon
gouvernement va pas jusque là
en même temps il ya toujours des
entreprises particulièrement des petites
entreprises qui ont l'impression que
c'est un grand fardeau que d'appliquer
la loi seraient donc sont un peu
déstabilisés par ce type de proposition
donc je pense que le gouvernement a fait
un assez bon compromis
faut pas aussi loin que certains
voudraient voir plus loin que d'autres
je pense par exemple notamment ou à
l'inversion du fardeau de la preuve pour
les entreprises lorsqu'on affiche une
promotion faudra qu'on prouve qu'on a
besoin de la connaissance de l'anglais
pour justifier dans la proposition du
post le côté qu'un soient bilingues
parce qu'actuellement on a l'impression
que tout le monde doit absolument parler
anglais dans tous les postes dans les
entreprises
alors qu'ils ont souvent aucun contact
avec des gens qui nécessite de parler en
anglais dons reçus de dire aux
entreprises cotées le suspect un
automatisme vous n'êtes pas obligé de
demander l'anglais pour chacun des
postes incluant le balayeur dans votre
entrepôt ça aussi c'est un message qui
était intéressant même si elle d'une
entreprise c'était me repose il ya
soixante quatre pour cent dans la région
de montréal des entreprises qui
demandent les deux langues
christian dufour écrit je devrais pas
répéter ce qu'on dit mes collègues
puissent choisir patrice bulting m'est
témoin je me suis beaucoup préparée pour
une analyse plus générale vallée du
projet donc chapeau un ciment jeu les
barrettes je trouve que c'est un projet
de loi qui est extrêmement travaillée on
ne pas attendu pour y est ça ratisse
très large en partie en fait ça
revitalise des choses qui existait déjà
dans la charte de la langue française
mais qu'on avait oublié souvent dit le
diable est dans les détails de la force
est dans les détails
j'ai rarement vu un projet ou qui est
arrivé sur la réalité dans les détails
dans le domaine concessionnaires
canadiens ce qu'ils voient un coup de
génie qui ont reçu leurs chèques
stamford conjonction la conjonction de
la clause dérogatoire où on se retire
quelque part du système canadien c'est à
dire le on protège le projet de loi de
la cour suprême et de la charte
canadienne des droits avec une insertion
dans la constitution canadienne ce fait
que le québec est une nation francophone
choses soient très très fort dans
quelque chose qui m'a été d'exclure
jean-christian que d'abord le québec a
le droit de penser ce site parce qu'on
n'a pas jamais de cet aspect là de la
console quand on peut chaque province
peut ajouter
un paragraphe 2 paragraphe c'est majeur
s'est passé pas linguistique comme tales
comme si la clause dérogatoire vous avez
bien de le souligner c'est légitime de
l'utiliser mon n'osait pas trop parce
que c'était négatif mais lost un système
qui est biaisé contre nous donc les
comme banalisée même les libéraux
admettre qu'on le fasse mais en même
temps ce qui est très fort c'est quand
même temps on s'insère dans le système
entendu on est une nation francophone -
donc juste pour finir mon truc plus
générale j'aimerais aussi que monsieur
le gouvernement dans le secours et
nationaliste très convaincant mais une
faille là dedans
une faille importante énormément de
mesures qui sont pas futile qui sont
rares mais dans la réalité dans le
détail mais ce qui manque
contrairement à la charte de la langue
française de camille laurin il manque un
projet structurant au centre parce que
monsieur legault en fait pas eu l'audace
d'appliquer la charte de la langue
française au cégep et se jette au second
et j'ai pas compris tu es juste terminée
c'est mon analyse générale six mois six
mois j'avais à rénover c'est le bal of
sexy mangeant des barrettes je trouve à
essayer par la bande de contenir en fait
le sujet par anglophone même de diminuer
à long terme la progression mais sauf
que ça va forcément valoriser
l'enseignement en anglais au niveau
collégial tout ce qui est rare est
précieux et je trouve que ça c'est la
grosse lacune et c'est monsieur legault
qui est un des responsables mais j'y
crois sinon jamais bon d'accord michel
david
je vais revenir aux particuliers le
commerce les la langue de travail
pour ce qui est des commerces bon y'a un
signal wi qui est envoyée maintenant le
processus là du client le kaki est pas
satisfait me semble un peu lourd à
porter plainte à l'office de la langue
française puis on n'est pas content
propre intenter des poursuites au civil
ça ça me semble extrêmement compliqué le
pour le consommateur j'ai trop pensé moi
que la meilleure façon d'être servis en
anglais en français c'était de
bouddhique de boycotter les commerces
cris qui servent pas à la règle et puis
quand les gens perdent des clients
ils finissent par comprendre pour ce qui
est de la francisation des entreprises
là on allège le processus quand même
pour les petites entreprises il y aura
des comités de francisation dans quelle
mesure ça va être vraiment très
contraignant ça reste vraiment à voir et
d'autre part l'exigence de du français
comme langue de travail actuellement
dans la loi il est déjà prévu que les
employeurs doivent faire la preuve qu'un
poste
et exige l'anglais le même principe
demeure alors d'une certaine façon on
repose encore largement le le
comment dire la décision sur la bonne
foi de l'entreprise
alors ça va dans la bonne direction mais
le résultat me semble pas évident
d'accord alors parlons-en du cégep
parce que certains voulaient puis josée
legault
vous avez dans une autre vie était
conseillère politique de monsieur
parizeau vous avez beaucoup travaillé
sur cette question et vous comme
d'autres à vide des constats assez
sévère plan remonte à plusieurs années
quand même et le larmes du cégep était
une arme avec laquelle vous auriez aimé
que le conte règle cette brèche la quête
une brèche selon vous ils sont pas allés
là on plafonne le pourcentage actuel
d'étudiants francophones
c'est ça qu'on fait il est à 17,9 dans
l'ensemble du québec
c'est pour certains c'est j'aime c'est
beaucoup plus comme nation et pour là
alors on dira jamais plus que 17 % de
francophones dans les échappements de la
fois qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
ce compromis et jauger si vous me
permettez de précision jamais concert
politique de monsieur parizeau
j'ai été nommé co directrice de bilan
exhaustif de la française par monsieur
parizeau spécialistes à l'époque en 95
avec une chaise dans ce corps à corps
avec michel plus odieuse une précision
et on avait déjà répertorié documenter
la le début de tous les reculs que l'on
constate aujourd'hui est le problème
c'est que tous les gouvernements
successifs n'ont su marier ce les
caddies sur le cégep
oui parce que c'est devenu les saisons
sont devenus des vecteurs
d'anglicisation très important on le
voyait déjà il ya 25 ans la proportion
de francophones et d'allophones on
oublie les allophones dans l'équation
augmenté continuellement succès
inscrivait au cégep malgré le fait
qu'ils avaient fréquenté le primaire et
le secondaire en français et on sait
pour les as loupé notre cause que ça
peut avoir comme conséquence et comme
choix de vie et choix de langues dans le
reste de leur carrière
donc non il ne l'a pas fait mais aucun
gouvernement va lui ne le fait non plus
et ce pour deux raisons je pense
la première c'est que bon le milieu des
affaires est absolument horripilé par
parler des bennes mais surtout je dirais
que chez les francophones eux mêmes
il ya quand même une bonne partie de
l'électorat et j'insiste sur le mot
l'électorat francophone qui tient
célébrer choix au collégial pour toutes
sortes de raisons à mon humble avis
c'est une erreur mais il ya un calcul
aussi électorale pas que la cacahuète
terriblement souffert parce qu'elle est
tellement au zénith dans les sondages
mais c'est sûr que ça aurait mis en
colère une partie de la population et m
shon avec monsieur legault le rappeler
même au sein du pq à l'époque puis jose
le soulignent nos véhicules ne pas fait
il y avait des discussions et la
majorité at il dit tout à l'heure
penchait du côté du libre-choix pour les
francophones si une famille si aux
jeunes francophones du valais au cégep
en anglais est dit qui sommes-nous pour
lui dire non c'est ça le le dilemme
oui mais quand même il ya eu un congrès
du parti québécois qui avait adopté le
principe de l'extension de la langue
française au cégep et madame marois
il s'y était ralliée au si elle ne
l'avait pas inclus dans son projet de
loi parce que le pq était minoritaire et
qui était clair d'avant cela que ni la
caq ni les libéraux n'appuieraient le
projet donc après pas le faire adopter
mais la volonté de le faire était là
c'est par la suite que le pq et change
d'idée est venu au libre-choix
maintenant moi je pense que ça aurait
été je rejoins questions là-dessus
s'arrêter là mesure que tout le monde
aurait retenu parce que l'autre façon
générale ya beaucoup de mesures c'est
vrai mais il n'y a rien qui frappe
l'imagination comme ça a été le cas avec
l'extension de la loi 101 au cégep
d'où le mot bouquet que j'utilisais que
ministre qui nous rappelle madame
vaudois est aussi allé y avait beaucoup
de mesures en mai mais juste pour tes
mais madame marois
quand même ce matin il le répétait
encore qu'elle n'était pas
nécessairement de cette vie là alors il
ya eu des jeux politiques au parti
québécois mais moi je suis persuadé que
le parti québécois au poids on n'aurait
jamais appliqué samedi
alec et puis on sentait que monsieur
legault enfin on se sent depuis le début
de ce débat là non ça aurait
probablement frappé l'imaginaire mais je
pense que ça aurait empoisonné le débat
est temps que empoisonné le des boys
s'est dit on va passer toute une série
de mesures assez costaude et on va pas
mettre une pilule dans le projet de loi
qui risque d'enflammer les esprits parce
que j'ose raison la cac en corse ont dit
récemment des sondages internes pour
voir c'est quoi la réception des
francophones à l'application de la loi
101 au cégep et ses deux tiers des
francophones qui s'y opposent en est à
65% au presque certain patrick avait pas
de problèmes au sujet est d'ailleurs des
choses intéressantes dans ce projet de
loi là je pense notamment au fait que
tout le monde même les diplômes
si on veut un diplôme d'un cégep
anglophone faudra passer l'épreuve
uniforme de français donc ça va obliger
les cégeps anglophones à donner des
cours de français à la hauteur d'être
capable de réussir l'épreuve uniforme de
français à la fin pour obtenir son
diplôme d'études collégiales ya le
plafonnement le contingentement donc la
réduit la croissance du réseau donc on
le comprend qu'il ya un problème avec le
réseau des cégeps que
on s'y attaque pas n'être pas de la
manière dont certains auraient voulu
mais d'une manière je pense qu'ils vont
être beaucoup plus facile à faire
accepter à la majorité francophone
oui à l'escrimé sur le terrain
le contingentement ça va être très
compliqué à ceux qui par les directions
des jeux si je peux ajouter c'est vrai
que les francophones ne voulait pas la
majorité mais indirectement ça va voir
ça pour effet parce qu'à partir du
moment où on plafonne et qu'on a sur la
priorité aux anglophones il va rester
moins de place pour les francophones
mais pour les anophèles alors c'est
exactement ce que la cac et libéraux
d'ailleurs avait au départ reprocher à
ce qu'ils voulaient
plafonner et introduire une priorité
pour les anglophones c'est à dire de
faire indirectement ce qu'ils n'osaient
pas faire directement
oui christian lell déception parce que
c'était la dernière occasion de le faire
en fait déposer la charte de la langue
française au cégep et ça me semble assez
clair qu'il fallait le faire
c'est monsieur legault lui même qui
compare le projet à la charte de la
langue française de camille laurin
camille lors elle l'avait fait il avait
imposé en fait la francisation des
immigrants au niveau scolaire et ça a
changé l'histoire
le projet de loi de ce mot jolie
barrette je le répète est très
intéressant il est habile il est très
très très travaillé il couvre très très
large il revitalise un tas d'aspects de
la chambre de princesse n'y a pas de cas
ne pas de musique structurantes et je
pense pas que ça a été controversée à ce
point là on est rendu là et les
arguments comme ceux le gode donné ce
matin moi je trouve que c'était décevant
l'argument deux heures que s'ils
permettent entre autres aux francophones
des régions d'apprendre l'anglais on est
comme le 165 6 mois je le regrette pour
le reste je trouve que le projet est
impressionnant et je le rappelle sur le
pack optionnel qu'elle asie un sujet qui
m'intéresse c'est un coup de maître
comme ça fait longtemps qu'on en dit
mais pourquoi monsieur le gone the
mercury mais il est symbolique christian
là ça change le symbole du français je
parle pas du français je viens sur le
plan contenait le calaisien pour parce
que beaucoup de choses à ce projet de
leur vie est très très riche c'est
dommage qu'on connaît pas beaucoup de
temps d'antenne aux plus que d'habitude
je vais monter deux chez les gays j'irai
juste juste mais c'est juste le coup de
maître concert calais et oublions la
l'angle depuis l'échec de l'accord du
lac meech
on n'a rien fait comme ça ces gagnants
devront se retire sans s'excuser d'un
système qui est biaisé contre nous
concessionnels man man mais ton sincère
en même temps c'est très très très
fécond c'est très étonnant quand
j'enregistre quand j'ai compris jeudi
benjamin deux ou trois zones de
commenter là dessus ce que j'ai
tellement bas lire une sur le sur cette
ag ou attention quand même moi j'ai vu
et tout va bien
michel david vous en pensez quoi de ce
cette idée qu'ils ont sortis de
d'ajouter un paragraphe dans
l'inconscient canadien c'est pas mauvais
mais d'abord ça s'est déjà fait on a
déjà ajouté des paragraphes
dans ce qu'on appelle la constitution
interne du québec et dans mon esprit
c'est la relation s'est largement
symbolique
je suis pas certain que devant les
tribunaux ça ferait une grande
différence mais enfin c'est mieux que
rien mais c'est aussi politique c'est à
dire que le lac hâte à la prochaine
élection par exemple va pouvoir dire
vous voyez mon projet nationaliste là
j'ai fait déjà un pas vers la
reconnaissance de la nation québécoise
mais est-ce que ça va vraiment plus loin
dans les faits que la motion que la
chambre des communes avait déjà adopté
chambre des communes pour reconnaître la
nation québécoise évidemment au sein du
canada mais mais quand même
ok le logo écrit au chili pour présenter
sa démarche trouve quelque chose de
créateurs de nouveau j'aime dernière
question pour vous tour de table la
chanteuse danoise avait permis a permis
de faire passer le transfert
linguistique de 25% qui était en 77
il y avait que 25 % des immigrés que les
verts français à 53 aujourd'hui il y en
a qui disent il faut monter sa 90 est-ce
que ce qu'on a présenté aujourd'hui va
faire monter le 53 oui ou non josé à
court terme non à moyen terme on ne le
sait pas ce sera une chose très
fondamental qu'il y avait derrière toute
l'idée de la loi 101 c'est à dire de
faire du passé
ce que camille laurens nommé la langue
normale et habituelle de toutes les
activités au québec hormis pour la
minorité doit notamment et ça ça demande
une présence massive sa demande
d'aménagement linguistique contraignant
et on n'est pas encore retourné tout à
fait là mais bon j'ai pas de boule de
cristal très bien avec
bon on ne le sait pas parce que pote
d'objectifs chiffrés dans ce projet de
loi là c'est peut-être l'une des
difficultés c'est à dire qu'on sait pas
de donner de chiffres à atteindre mais
le fait d'avoir un organisme en espèces
de guichet unique la francisation québec
autant pour les entreprises que pour les
nouveaux arrivants parce qu'en plus le
fouillis l'oeil et des cours de français
a offert aux militants éducation et non
ministère de l'immigration
à quoi ça ressemble d'abord peut-être un
endroit où chacun des migrants vont
pouvoir s'adresser on le prend
alors qu'on lui donne les cours de
français ça peut certainement pas nuire
aux transferts comme celle david pour
arriver à 192% je pense que c'est un peu
il y aura mais pour lui d'y augmenter
substantiellement il faudrait faire en
sorte que ça soit presque pas possible
ils ont de vivre au québec sans
connaître le français et je pense pas
que ce projet de loi là même s'ils
constituent un progrès va faire en sorte
que ça sera plus possible de comment
dire de fonctionner dans la société sans
cesse et christian le mot de la fin vous
assure ralliement en fait la société
québécoise des forces vitales dusty
québécoise autour de ce projet là ça
pourrait changer des choses mais je
pense qu'on va voir aliments et au
défaitisme très profond entre auch et
des faiseurs d'opinion au québec leur me
servait juste pas vous aujourd'hui entre
je pars parce que je veux me faire
couper la tête par la publicité pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit